I tried to [ __ ] a lady but I couldn't do
it right I really wanted to be able to
do it I wanted to be the guy who could
do it that's the problem I couldn't do
it either what what happened hard you
just weren't you're gay well English is
a problem obviously
no no cater to tourists but did you try
I tried went in looking to do it it all
came around me I found a couple hot ones
huh
you know how much some lady boys are
like they're different than [ __ ] here
they're very girls different I said to
Brody Stephens I go dude this she was
playing with his hair a head and I said
dude I'm gonna tell you right now if you
bring that chick home if you bring that
guy home my girls were out there for
that further hangover I go you are not
gay and if anybody calls you gay I will
defend you to the end say that's a best
little hot woman man I've ever seen in
my life what and Brody's like well I
don't know you know he's not gonna do it
he took it to the limit that me what
does that mean he goes let's just say he
might have almost went all delicious
yeah like what's worse what's what's
gayer [ __ ] an uglier person or a
hotter person who both look like a woman
humans a human yeah humans a human well
no you know what it would be you'd have
to be in jail with this person for a
while and then you would end up banging
him no you are you are gay man so you
know he's been pretending is so in Seoul
he [ __ ] sends me pictures you got
buckles on his boots he sent me a
picture with a [ __ ] Johnny with a hat
with a Johnny Depp hat it's not really
quite a fedora it's like it's like a a
wide-brimmed round it was so cute and
sexy and he's got it propped on the back
of his head where you would wear a
yarmulke like so it's if I gotta jump
through the phone my bummer is that I
can't beat him up I can't slap him
around - we sent you and daliyah the
picture sometimes I do it just to piss
you guys off oh I was furious they don't
do you think they're homophobic is that
what dude [ __ ] you really scares me with
snakes scare me spiders don't scare I
see black widows around like
about time I although I like I'm taking
care of now because my son yeah yeah
spiders don't scare me insects lizards I
see lizards all the time
caught when my house giant ass lizard
nothing they don't scare you when you
walk bottom though I didn't come out of
nowhere
another cool I had a pet lizard on skin
iguana - walk down leash like a cat
I've get goes I had [ __ ] anoles I had
all sorts of weird animals yes my lizard
like a cat not a lot of friends back
then cats
you can walk cats like I do wag and
someone had their Bengal which bengals
are like craziest but Bengal tiger
no the little Bingle excuse me the
Bengal cats a little Garfield's no they
don't like Garfield's they're the ones
that Jon Jon has Jon Jones the tiny oh
no you talk about the thing that's mixed
with like a goddamn mountain line
something like that how much a small cat
yeah I'm walking track what you walk a
lizard cat sorry I'm getting off topic
no I'm with you that is [ __ ] weird
does snow walk like you meant either dog
or you did you see Walker naughty
swapping cat Z he was really out of
shape and they made me walk American
hilarious his name was Zeke he was
singing out of shape my mom made me walk
him and I read the leash was like a shoe
string because they can't like a dog
leash and then I was at the storm for my
birthday
I remember if it was my birthday or my
brother's birthday you had to get both
of his a gift because I feelings to be
hurt if the other one got gifts I mean
so my brother got a pair of Jordans
again we didn't grow up super rich so my
brother got a pair of like they were
Jordan fives at the time which I have
him now that my favorite show of all
time
Jordans fought for that reason me and my
brother loved them my Billy got joined
fives and I got a pet iguana and the guy
was yeah so we heard how's the weird
[ __ ] Crocodile Hunter as a kid the
guy the pet stores like we're gonna need
a leash I was like yeah I'm gonna need
Elise
he's like cuz they need exercise like
all the other and I was like you're
[ __ ] right man and so I put on him and
I was walking him and I was like trying
to show off to my friends and the thing
just freaked out like like rolled and
like the whole [ __ ] night
it's amazing how these animals have have
advanced and how they have evolved over
the years you believe that the world is
ten thousand years old and flat though
right whoo I do not I do not sir you
tell me nope you told me research
breading rumors now oh no I'm not so
you'd rather grade this Christian
fundamentalist thing around me and I'm
not that guy yeah but Brian you said
that you said if I know my friend
Brian yeah careful recently I'm not I'm
not trying to spread [ __ ] again you
claimed that the earth is 10,000 years
old and flat okay I never said that yes
you're spreading rumors now and I think
and you were you said you said I it was
a while ago okay careful now it was like
about a year and a half ago you said by
gum the world is 10,000 years old they
buy and it's flat or Ted Cruz will not
be the next president of the United
States
I never said that's what you said I'm
sorry I didn't say that's reporting the
net stick your whole hand up your ass I
don't know anything about actually
wrestling I don't know I'm just saying I
watch it now or boxing yeah but you or
my feet yeah but you jump around you
jump around in a gym right I'll say jump
around you jump around in a gym jump I'm
yeah if I catch angle no no you put on
house of pain and you jump around and
you jump around in there and [ __ ] you
and Tony right no way Michalek the great
way Mac all right so you jump around and
he pretend throws you know the focus
pads and you're like remember this do do
it like this
bet bet bet bet pet pet pet pet like a
three-year-old would just go tit or you
know when girls teach each other pad no
that's not what right it's like that's
what no it's exactly what it looks like
Wow
now let's play pattycake when I turn my
plants are they over when I sit down and
my punches yeah when I sit down you ever
hear a gun go off yes bang bang but that
bang yeah that's not what your punches
so who's shooting the machine gun they
say
I'm just saying he's off in the distance
here when they're when they're behind
the closed door of my gym right and I'm
working yeah
and I'm putting in work as we say in the
light game yeah but then you but you
shouldn't say that but well that's what
they say you don't deserve to say that
and I'm just saying that but when I put
in work yeah they go I got a funny story
about this they go
who's shooting the machine gun by the
way what I love about boxing and when
you're an actor like me and you're 50
and you you're right
hop around the ring and maybe I spar
with headgear with the guy who's really
never boxed before and I still get hit
and and you know maybe I get the best of
him because he hasn't been doing it this
long or maybe he's just not very
athletic what'll happen is you you will
trainers when they're talking to
somebody else in front of you you know
what they'll say it's great and of
course they know better and they'll say
they'll sake to make you feel good and
look good though bro this guy's got
skills he can box oh and of course I of
course I can't of course I can
and-and-and I know what they're doing
right but it's very common for them to
give you props even if you suck right
and it's almost like if they're I don't
know what it is but there's almost a
thing for that in that way just be I
know he's got skills he can move around
well of course they're keeping it
positive
they're keeping it around the gym put me
every one time with a guy and a good
amateur and I get knocked out I don't
know about that I don't know about that